Charles good morning how are you what
I'm doing great man are you I'm doing
okay how many pro bowls did you make
made nine altogether how many times did
you go to the pro bowl and play you know
I think I actually went for four times
five times [ __ ] how do you get out of
there room for going the other times how
did you get out of going yeah because
guys who will say you know I got surgery
is that usually the key that hey I'm
glad to be making the Pro Bowl but I got
this surgery that I gotta have yeah it's
usually a injury you know after you at
the each season I mean everybody could
probably claim something and so you know
a lot of guys will say you know you
don't have a surgery or I was dealing
with you know this particular injury all
season long so I'm gonna give myself a
chance to rest and not go and play in an
all-star game so that's usually how it
goes what did you think of the NBA
voting where Steph Curry and James
Harden are going to start in the
all-star game but Russell Westbrook is
averaging a triple-double and he's not
starting I how how big is it how
important is it do you think from the
player's perspective to start as opposed
to coming off the bench well you know I
think in this case is one of those
things um I think it's kind of like the
Hall of Fame you know you every year
somebody goes in and somebody else is
basically snubbed you know for lack of a
better word but how do you argue against
the guys that are going in you know so
for this this particular you know deal
with the all-stars you know stepping
hard enough you know two of the best
players in the game but then when you
look at Russell Westbrook and a goddess
you know averaging the triple double you
can't fathom how this guy's not starting
on the office are getting so I see the
argument both ways I guess I watched
you're a cohort randy moss on the NBA
show he was talking about he would he
could average 20 when he was if he
played in the NBA in his prime and and
we look at Randy Moss says he was a big
guy in the NFL a tall guy in the NFL
right like it ready mas was on the floor
in the NBA it would take you a couple of
minutes to go which ones mosh because
he'd only 65 right yeah yeah yeah the
only way man he would have it so he
would have had to been a point guard in
the NBA big board so he would have been
one of those guys rented didn't know
what he was trying to play he would have
been a tweener he knows he might not see
many might have seen many minutes on the
court best best athlete at ESPN is who
i'm going with myself okay all right
what about what about aside from you
aside for me yeah oh great Randy all day
better than rose or any of the NBA guys
after I begin hey Jalen Rose if it yeah
yeah you know Jalen's Ellen was uh I
mean I only know him as a basketball
player you know what I think Ashley's I
think of a guy that can do everything
and you know myself I know I could do it
all growing up and still think I can and
Brandi Brandi Lyn same way so you speak
of athletes guys that can pretty much go
into any arena and be effective you know
you're gonna start with up to which
quarterback in his prime would you want
to face or of all these quarterbacks if
you consider Brady still in his prime
considering the year that he had but of
these four ranked the the one you would
want to face and maybe the one that you
would not want to face who would be the
one you would want to face the one I
would want to say I guess I would have
to say a big bin as a defensive player
because I know you know being the way he
scrambles you know out of pocket it up
he's always looking to take shot
downfield so as a defender you know
you're going
have that opportunity to make plays on
the ball so I would go then as the guy
that I would I would want to say besides
the other guy you know it with with
Rogers and Brady man they take such good
care of the football you know it's hard
to get in one of the past passes they
have you know unbelievable you know
track records especially you know this
season of taking care of the football
each other you know and single digits in
the interception so those guys right now
course other covers with Aaron Rodgers
having the added ability to scramble you
know more than the Brady so old guys are
tell the trucker's are nothing when did
you know what was the moment where you
kind of show Rodgers you went okay the
guy's a real deal as a teammate I happen
in practice every day no he was on the
scout team you know when I first got
there Brett Favre of being a quarterback
of course I mean me and a rod used to
play you know these cat mouse games
together every day in practice you know
you know me being on the defensive and
it's going against him in that scout
team and he could make unbelievable
throws he was unbelievably accurate you
know at that time but i think that the
time when he got into the game but
thinking 2007 against dallas the dallas
cowboys threat went when i was an injury
and a where i got into the game and you
know he almost led us back to a comeback
victory but i think you know just
watching him everybody on that sideline
was watching his young kids swing the
ball around and have such great command
of the office you know having been
having that being his first time really
getting into action in a regular season
game and it was beautiful to see and i
think that that was the very moment when
you know everybody you know said you
know the moments I too big too big for
him the shadow of playing behind Brett
Favre is not too big for him once he
gets his shot he's gonna be ready to
roll was Roger's better than favre at
that time no no it wasn't very far me
father Tsar was special I mean didn't
make no mistake about it
but as far as a guy who like i said
before who didn't seem to mind you know
the pressure of being the guy behind
Brett Aaron definitely had that
confidence and you knew like I said once
he got his shot you know you Packers
were going to be in good hands it's
charles woodson from the mothership
joining us dan Patrick shell the Tuck
anniversary but what happens on the on
the anniversary was yesterday on the
Raiders and the Patriots do you
acknowledge that day at all Charles no I
don't acknowledge it and you know it's
funny I you know we talked about it
yesterday I got a call and somebody
reminded me that it was anniversary and
I'm like Jesus I was out there on the
golf course and I was I was changing
ball hit right I couldn't figure out why
this in all the sudden I'm Orion were
reminded that it's their anniversary of
the trouble and like no wonder I can't
hit a ball so yeah you know it's uh you
know it that game is to me it's kind of
it's kind of weird or not weird but it
seems so crazy that it's been 15 years
you know it's a long time ago what every
day after you know Charles after that
hit after the fumble what's the referee
say to you I don't I don't think I had
any interaction with the referee I
remember hitting Brady seeing the ball
out and I was able to see a great
because recover and then I was I was
ready to ride off into the sunset you
know I'm celebrating running into the
running to the sideline and then all of
a sudden it they said that they're going
to review it and I I mean I I don't
nobody on that side like I could
understand what they were actually
reviewing so I didn't have any
interaction with the official at what do
you think Raider fans will follow the
Raiders to vegas at some point do they
just say you know what enough with this
you know kind of toying with our
emotions here or are they that long off
not not it there's that lawyer is going
to sing of course if the raiders pick up
the move but the Raiders fans are low
fans are you going to lose some I mean
that's just the nature of it some people
are going to be better with it but a
vast majority of Raider fans are Raiders
fans regardless and they'll follow the
latest wherever they may go have fun
this weekend and of course with the Pro
Bowl by the way what it was at Guildford
the guilt for Brooklyn is that what
happened a couple of weeks ago it was
still what happened it was still for
right you guys were laughing it was
built for not not at it in heaven that
not none of our guys to do this they
were done now now we were doing of
course you wouldn't matuwir to class be
up there of course of course of course
you nobody would do that but I think
bill forget how we were and of course
you wouldn't course have fun this
weekend great to talk to you again
Charles thanks for joining us I that's
like Charles Woodson the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience
[Music]